should we kick it off well thanks for
coming along um and today i'm going to
talk about
uh
building apis and how some of the
fastest growing perhaps most famous api
companies in the world
approach some of the problems they face
on their api journey and i've been lucky
i've like worked quite a few of them
actually and
all of the pain i talk about today
i talk about from a very personal
perspective i felt that pain on the
bleeding edge or at least talk to people
who went through it recently so i feel
it's like fairly first-hand
um a little bit about me uh i'm british
actually a british i should say but i've
been in the states so long now i dropped
my t's
and i used to be a software engineer
here
studied in london
um
moved back up north where i'm from and i
was a software architect up there work
for a travel company where one of my
sort of coding horror stories for today
will come from
and then i joined microsoft and they
moved me to redmond which is why i live
in the seattle area which is probably
makes me the furthest traveled actually
at the room um at microsoft i was really
lucky i got to start a bunch of products
that you probably know a few of them
actually if you're all microsoft fans so
azure mobile services was was one of the
projects i started at microsoft uh uh
azure api management it's actually a
competitor to the product i i now
founded um was founded by me as an
acquisition we acquired a
company called epiphany which is such a
great name i wish it was still available
um and then i went on to run the
integration portfolio so looking after
old tech like biz talk anyone familiar
with this talk server
yeah a couple of hands sorry about that
it wasn't me though i just looked after
it towards the end of it is anyone still
using it you put the hand up
no okay good um
uh and then it's replacement logic apps
was actually created on on my teams and
so was it was called microsoft flow
originally but i think they recently
renamed it to power automate home server
edition r2 or some crazy thing right um
so that's changed then i went to
facebook where i worked on a product
called facebook analytics which was the
most fun you have ever had until a
certain event called cambridge analytica
happened and even though it had nothing
to do with cambridge analytica i stopped
doing press calls after that moment as
you can imagine it was pretty much the
death of the product honestly
i founded facebook music and worked on
lasso which you haven't heard of
but it became instagram reels which if
you use instagram you've probably seen
uh it's like a tiktok competitor really
fun i had a really fun experience doing
that then i worked at stripe for a
little while where i was head of payment
methods lots of api learnings there uh
that looked after the apis for all of
the different payment payment methods
they have worldwide um except for credit
cards
so a ton of fun and then recently last
year i founded my own company called
zuplo
in the gateway space
that's a little bit about me we're
actually sponsors of the of the event so
we have a little booth downstairs i've
probably already given most of you a
little card that has this qr code on it
so this qr code takes you to an exercise
if you some of you done it a couple of
faces but actually not many if you
complete this exercise you can win a
drone which is kind of cool i don't know
what you do with it but you can win one
then we've only had five entries so far
so you've got a seriously good chance of
winning a drone if you complete the
exercise like it's well worth doing it
if you fully complete the exercise and
come and show us at the booth we will
give you instantly give you a five
dollar starbucks gift card yes it's in
dollars i had to buy it in america but
it does work here um so you can still
buy a coffee with it i think i find it's
well worth it it's well worth giving
that a try and just seeing the product
in action
um so what we're going to talk about
today though is
the api journey people go we go through
particularly going to focus on public
apis so that means an api where
some of the business or some of the
customer uses the api that's going to be
the main focus there'll be some
learnings potentially for for internal
apis as well but i'm mostly going to
talk about about public apis that's what
i i worked on in my career um we're
going to look at how some of those
companies you know the common approach
is actually you'll find there's a lot of
commonalities in the lessons they learn
and the things they do to solve these
problems it'll also explain why i
started the business i started and you
know what can you do to get ahead
um
so when we think about the journey of
like launching an api that i'm going to
share like maybe i'm an api first
business or or actually maybe i'm not an
api first business but eventually most
businesses end up need to share some
kind of api for integration purposes or
for a large customer to upload inventory
even if your primary business isn't apis
and you kind of go through a few phases
um
first when you're launching you know
you've got to think about the basics
and this is where actually most people
start building themselves so things like
authentication protection i'll go
through all these how do you document
the api so that people know how to use
it seems obvious but you know something
you've got to do and you should do a
good job of i think
how many people here you know you're all
software developers right is anybody not
a software developer
everybody writes code and how many
people say would say they feel a sense
of craft about what they do like when
they put something into their work and
they share it with another developer
there's a sense of pride about that
right like you want to feel good about
it looks good you want them to like like
your design and think your api looks
pretty is that true
i certainly feel that very strongly so
yeah it seems like there's lots of nods
um so that's another thing and then when
you get into growth into sort of the
growth stage like you're past the
beginning you passed the launch you're
starting to think about things like
scaling and you know hopefully you
already thought about versioning but
not everybody does at the beginning um
we'll talk about some some funny stories
that are abstraction
becomes really really critical
and something everybody needs eventually
and there's sort of common answers to
that and then as you get later there's
sort of consistency and compliance i
actually met bill gates a couple of
times at microsoft working on this
problem the last one
and yesterday i met a person here whose
job at a company
was to
maybe he's here i don't know it was to
police other developers inside his
company to make sure they were using the
tools they had decided like he was like
the api cops or something um so that's
right this is a real problem certainly
like larger more mature businesses if
you're a startup you don't tend to worry
about that stuff too much
let's talk about the launch phase first
so there's four things you really need
before you go and launch your public api
you're gonna need authentication duh
otherwise how do you know who's calling
the api you need a good solution for
that we'll talk about the classic battle
in the public api landscape
and you're gonna need protection we'll
talk about what that means
and documentation obviously and you
should launch with some analytics and in
each case i'm going to list out for you
some of the obvious options on the table
that you can use um
we'll go through them you'll start to
spot a pattern emerge so first of all
let's talk about authentication uh who
has uh who has that you're building a
public api right you're gonna you're
gonna share it with someone outside of
your company potentially gonna have some
sort of sign up i think the mic's going
in and out is that right
can you hear me when it goes out though
am i loud enough okay cool
i think there's this like battle between
do you use jot authentication or do you
use api keys and i'm a big fan of job
tokens don't get me wrong um big fan
actually uh all zero the leadership
everyone's heard of all zero right
the identity company they're they're the
leaderships investors in in my startup
i'm good friends with all those folks
they're very big into the jock game
they've almost tried to claim ownership
of it with jot that i owe
but should you use api keys and like
what's the way to think about this this
decision when you're launching a public
api like what's the reasoning for making
a decision between these two things
anybody got a stake in the game who
would who would say the best way to go
is to go with a jot token
no hands up who would say the best way
to go is an api key one hand over there
and then just lots of people who aren't
willing to take the gamble far enough
it's okay well what are these i think
these are all pretty famous companies
who
you know have a an api that is well
known right the stripe everyone sort of
stripe right of course twilio very
famously one of the best api first
companies like kind of made kind of made
the market for this like how to launch
an api error table is another great
example and then github
what do they all have in common
they all use api keys every single one
of them
and why is that let's let's look at two
reasons
first of all
see let's acknowledge the problem what
is the problem with api keys they're not
standardized and that feels kind of icky
like there's no
protocol that says this is how to do an
api key this is how to format one this
is the exchange mechanism
it's kind of a bit of a free-for-all so
that's that's why they feel a little bit
icky but
actually in reality when done properly
they're very secure and in fact there's
some debate about whether they're more
secure for a public api program than a
jot token i'm not going to get into that
argument i'm confident they're secure
because look at all the people that use
them you know stripe is like a financial
api it's not a it's not a toy um but
there's some advantages from a security
angle you know those tokens are opaque
if you take a look at a jot token you
can actually decode that and see all the
claims inside not everybody feels great
about that like maybe i'm leaking some
details about my security implementation
typically with an api key design as well
it's much easier to very quickly revoke
an api key like all of these services
have self-serve facilities for you to go
and revoke your api key if it gets
leaked they have all kinds of magic in
place on github like if you check in a
stripe live key into github it'll
automatically be revoked and you'll get
an email telling you you checked in one
of your keys so there's lots of nice
features that make this actually a very
very secure space but that's not the
real reason why they do it
the real reason why they do api keys in
these things is all about adoption
so if you've ever read i think his name
is jeff wilson the ceo of twilio he has
a great book called ask your developer
it's really good readout i'd strongly
recommend it and twilio was one of these
first
big api first companies and they
obsessed about this metric called ttfc
time to first call and so what i have up
on the screen here
is a funnel how many people are like
familiar with a marketing funnel or like
an adoption funnel pretty
straightforward concept right so
lots and lots of people come in and view
your website and then some percentage of
them actually sign up
and then some test your api and then
some percentage of that become customers
and if you can improve the conversion at
each step you're going to end up with
more customers or more adoptees of your
program and that's one of the main
reasons why they use api keys because at
this test api this time to them
successfully getting a first call they
obsess about getting that time to first
call down and there's one guaranteed way
of increasing that time and that's use a
complex jot authentication flow with
like refresh mechanisms like instantly
you've just increased the complexity of
adopting your api whereas the good old
api key
you're done and so that's why it's very
very popular amongst api first companies
it's what we recommend at zuplo we
support this as well but we also support
jot tokens but uh i'm going to be
opinionated today if nothing else
so these are some of the options you
have if you want to do this so if you
want to go with jo you can build your
own you've always got the option of
building your own you can use products
like identity server and key cloak and
of course even auth0 has uh
has some products here azure ad octa or
you can use a gateway like con console
we'll talk about those in a minute if
you're using api keys you can build your
own which is actually what most people
do they start from scratch have a
database somewhere with keys and
customers in it
there's not a ton of options of open
source products that i can find out
there so if you know of any actually
tell me i love to like share
different options in this space there's
a thing for netflix called service stack
that seems to be a paid like licensable
service where they'll give you
api keys if that's what you need to do
and then of course most of the gateways
in the market have an option to help you
with this
so now let's move on to protection
um
when i talk about protection what i'm
really saying is rate limiting is adding
a rate limit to your to your public api
and i have a lot of conversations about
this and they go one of two ways the
conversation starts by someone saying to
me
i think i need rate limiting because i'm
new i'm just getting started and
anonymous are not out to get me it turns
out it's not anonymous that are going to
take you down it's not the hacker that's
behind the mask that's going to that's
going to hit your api so hard they're
going to take down your back end
it is always your customer it is a
clumsy for loop in their code
and so the other half of the
conversations i have are people are like
oh yeah that happened last week how many
people have have an api and they've
either taken themselves down internally
with like a react code react is terrible
for this it's very easy to write a four
loop and react how many folks have had
an api taken down by or or hit too hard
by someone where it was just clumsy code
anybody
nearly half of you it sounds that sounds
about right so it's really important to
did someone say something
no it's really really important to have
something in place for this when you
launch your api the num the number of
folks when they launch that the back end
is taken down and actually even if
you're not an api first customer you'll
often find that can take down your your
primary core business as well which is
not a good idea so make sure you have
protection in place uh find a library
there's tons of libraries out there you
can just search for for rate limiting
libraries you can build your own uh one
of the problems with a lot of the
libraries is they don't work in the
distributed way very well many of them
um so you know let's imagine you have
like edge presence or you have you know
your api served from multiple locations
around the globe then
that rate limiting has to be coordinated
around the globe that's a kind of a
non-trivial problem to solve
and so not many of the libraries do that
some do it depends on the language you
can build your own using red as it's you
know it's not that hard um take some
management take some stuff to keep it
going there's a very cool open source
service called gubernator i think it was
built by mail gun that can help with
this and most of the gateways api
gateways in the market will solve this
problem for you as well
so docs i'm not going to spend too much
time on this
i'm enjoying getting you putting hands
up though i'm going to get you exercised
by the time we leave here i promise you
so who thinks docs are important for a
good developer experience
of course you do actually well someone
shout me out what's a good example who's
got some good docs whose docs do you
look anything you know they're just
great any companies you can think of
swagger
was that what someone said
nice okay yeah and like open api
specification as a way of generating
docs that's pretty cool what it doesn't
have to be about apis though just like
companies that have good docs that you
use anybody anybody stand out to you
you like microsoft's yeah yeah they're
pretty good they got really good
actually didn't they i think they really
improved over the last like
five or so years i think jeff sandquist
team anybody else
who was that
aws
oh i hate their docs but anyway you know
that's uh
we're here to disagree it's all good
it's all good um i mean other companies
i think stripes quite famous for doing
it quite well uh zeros docks are
excellent actually um there's tons of
companies but we all know it's very
important so this is something i'd
recommend investing in particularly if
you have a public public api
i've mentioned some of the options of
services you can use here to help you
very quickly get good docs for your apis
so there's build your own i don't know
why you'd build your own today
that seems mad but you can um you can
use swagger somebody said which which
actually is as much a specification as
it is a documentation tool but it's very
well known everybody heard of open api
specification and swagger yeah
people use it
yeah yeah okay uh there's things like
rapid dark which is an open source
skin over swagger uh readme which is
kind of the same thing but it's a
charged product redoxly stoplight is
pretty cool most of the gateways have
this stuff too
so pretty easy and then analytics i'm
not really going to get into analytics
too much you folks know you should have
some measurement in place when you
launch your api so you know what the
hell's going on i don't need to sort of
go into the reasoning of that too much
there's a couple of well-known products
here i think you're interesting most cf
api metrics
most of the gateways will have some
we'll have some analytics metrics for
you as well
so now let's talk about the the growth
phase of um
launching an api so we're now launched
hopefully you know maybe you're getting
some customers or you're your first
partners are on board and they love you
they're very proud of the you know
they're very excited about how easy it
was to integrate with your company and
you're getting a pat on the back from
your boss which is the goal then you've
got to start thinking about things like
versioning what am i going to do when i
launch version two
um
abstraction because you don't always
need to version you can dance around it
i'll i'll tell a story about that in a
minute um although you should think
about versioning obviously when we get
out of it so i actually think it's very
smart to at least think about these
things before you launch right
uh you will save yourself a lot of pain
than
uh going in and solving this problem
later and there's a lot of easy ways of
doing that
but let's talk about versioning an api
and
we may not all agree here this is
absolutely fine it's a healthy
discussion
um
and so uh what i what i'm curious about
is like how do folks like to version
their apis today i see two main ways
personally i see url based versioning
and header based versioning so you know
you send something like a v3 in the
accept header or some custom header that
says what version
hands up if you're in the hands up if
you're in the adult version the api camp
and it's okay we've all been there
okay one person with the guts to do it i
appreciate that uh
anybody in the url based versioning
okay that's probably just about most of
you anybody in the accept
header based versioning okay a smaller
number which is probably about the same
as what you see when we look at those
companies probably about the same
distribution actually
most of them are url based twilio stripe
or table this is a small sample but i
find this this holds true probably
across a large number github uses the
accept header
um if i'm going to get opinionated about
it which which i'm willing to do i
personally do prefer url based
versioning and i'll use the git
uh as a concrete example so with github
their api
you'll look at their docs it says you
send an accept header and i think it's
uh you know application slash json.v3 or
something and that v3 tells them which
versions of the api you want to use but
then there's this weirdness
if you don't send an accept header they
say we're just going to assume you mean
v3 because that's the one we want you to
use it feels really dangerous to me
because now if i've got customers that
are not sending that accept header and i
update the default version i just kind
of break everybody and so there's
something beautiful about putting the
version in the url
it's part of the address like nothing
works without that being extremely
explicitly placed inside the url and i
think honestly i think i think in its
favor
i think of stripe twilio and er table
and much more api first businesses
whereas github you know it's a source
control first business their api is not
their primary way of doing business um
and i think that's why folks like this
obsess about these details a little more
honestly so personally i'm in the url
base camp um
and i think that's a better way a more
friendly easier way to aversion your api
let's talk about stripe though and their
versioning so they do url based
versioning and if you go and look at
their quick start today which is
excellent they're the tutorial that
guides you how to accept a payment
it dances around the code as you scroll
through the instructions it's really
cool
and you'll see if you're looking in
their curl example that this is the url
that you hit
v1 payment intents
so how many versions of the stripe api
do we think there's been since stripe
launched in like
i don't know 2010 or something
how many anyone willing to take a guess
10.
he knows it's not one it's like the main
point so i i appreciate it um
there's been obviously there's been many
i'm not going to go into like that
between minor and major breaking changes
you're all software developers you all
know that um
there's been many minor changes to the
api obviously like i i don't know the
count uh but there's been so far three
massive breaking changes to the stripe
api so why does it still say v1
because they just used a different
section after the v1 they just came up
with totally different apis so they had
the first api was called charges
and then they totally changed the design
it's still they still actually support
v1 charges api and then they did v2
which was called sources i think it was
before i was there
and
that's still available as v1 sources and
so when they launched payment intents
which was that they're obsessed with
this notion of a
a decade-long abstraction they're trying
to create these abstractions around
payments
that that are so
powerful they can account for any kind
of payment method even ones they haven't
thought about that so that the api
design will last 10 years
very divisive topic at stripe actually
uh some good friends of mine um quit
stripe because they were so frustrated
with how complex stripe were making the
api by trying to achieve that it
actually reminds who was familiar with
wcf at microsoft the communication
foundation
there's some like uh some reactions to
wcf i'm also friends with vittorio
bertocchi if you know if you remember
him um and uh yeah that was a similar
idea like we're gonna create this one
abstraction overall messaging
and it's gonna rule the world didn't
quite work out right it was just
insanely complex
and so there's some debate at stripe
whether they're making the right call by
going for these decade longer
abstractions but that's a little
tangential story for you
so by launching payment intents it's a
v1 of that api
so
they didn't need to actually change the
version now maybe one day they do a v2
of payment intents but it just gives you
actually the reason i like the story is
it gives you a sense of the abstractions
available to you when you think about
about changing your api if you're making
such a fundamental change it might be
actually to think about it as a v1 of a
different api and that's totally
acceptable you know it's going to work
if people can still do the use the
charges api by the way it will be
deprecated at some point and that's just
a product of your approach to how long
you want to support those old customers
you know that's that's really a business
decision how long do you want to leave
that thing lying around to give them the
chance to move to your
to your latest version make sense
um so what are your options when it
comes to versioning i honestly i don't i
think this i don't know of a library or
um
like an open source product you can use
to help you with versioning if you know
of one please tell me i like to build a
list of these things and share it
um you really just kind of have to have
a bit of a plan uh honestly what most
people do is they stick a v1 in their
api url and they're good for now you
know they'll work it out we'll just in
time this we'll we'll work it out later
maybe i never need it because maybe i
launch
v1 something else in the future and
that's fine as well but you really do
want to be thinking about this stuff
i might have mentioned i think url is
the way to go the other option again use
a gateway gateways can really help you
with this
so let's talk about abstractions um
and
i've seen this multiple times now about
the importance of this um so i'll tell
some war stories so first of all i
mentioned i founded the azure api
management team at microsoft and so
that was a pro anyone familiar with
azure api management anybody use it
oh you actually are customers of that
product
cool
um
how do you feel about it thumbs up
thumbs down
yeah yeah i left for a reason
um
uh
funny story i actually left the team
with it's probably live stream hello
team hello old folks all the people who
used to work with me on that they signed
up for my wait list of my products i'm
like no you're not coming in no you're
not you're not having access um
so yeah well a lot of a lot of lessons
though were
uh people are generally doing some kind
of projection so you know you've built
an api
and you're probably using it internally
and then all of a sudden you're using it
like your own react client is using that
api so it's all like really
tightly integrated and you've made all
kinds of shortcuts and then one day a
partner shows up and this is a great
problem to have this is like the
stickiest best customer problem to have
is when a customer comes to your
business and says do you have an api we
can integrate with like integrate our
erp into or whatever it is that's a
fantastic problem to have because once a
customer does that they're very sticky
you know it's very hard for them to move
to another to another platform so having
a customer integrate with an api it's
beautiful it's like it's great
but then you've got this challenge where
you're like oops so
now i have an api but it's really not
ready to share with a customer probably
has like the wrong shape or has some
properties on it the customer shouldn't
see
and so one of the nice things these
gateways can do is they can put like a
new authentication layer on it like you
know like api keys for example azure api
management can do that
um
can generate the docs for you can do
some basic transformation right like so
you like maybe you can strip fields off
or change headers or or and make it a
more uh publicly appealing api that's
one of the benefits actually of starting
out early with the right abstraction
layer so even for your internal apis
having a gateway tends to be a good
thing to do in the beginning because it
just gives you lots of option value in
the future
should you want to um should you want to
show this api and then
so when i was at microsoft because i was
the the lead of the api management team
um everyone knows who scott guthrie is
right
yeah he asked me to lead a project that
was called one api
it's long enough for now i don't think
they'll get angry at me for talking
about it and the goal was is that at
microsoft we had we had just this
disparate
awful mix of of different apis with like
different authentication schemes so like
azure is pretty good now actually i
haven't looked at some of these for a
while so my information may be a little
dated but
azure has pretty consistent apis you use
this thing called azure resource manager
i think is the the sort of the the
orchestration engine for it but then if
you go and sign up for bing's apis or
you go and sign up for the office 365
apis or
other product team they're just
completely different than they're not
they weren't very
and some other companies were doing this
much better like google actually has a
sense of a very consistent approach the
way they have all of their apis across
gcp
across their docs products etc and
that's a really nice place to be because
this is where we talk about the
compliance and the consistency end of
the scale
um
you know i'll be honest one api is one
of the hardest failures i've had in my
career we were not able to sort that
mess out
everything was too different people were
too siloed we came at the problem far
too late it was just like moving heaven
and earth it was very hard to get
something done and so
one of the lessons there is the sooner
you start thinking about having an
abstraction in place where everybody is
routed through the same abstraction the
easier it's going to be to achieve that
compliance and that consistency later in
the day and i don't know how much
progress microsoft have made on this
since but the reason it's really
important i mean imagine how many
developers use office 365's api right
like a lot of people or how many people
use the azure api and from a business
point of view they want every developer
that uses that to be very easily able to
move sideways and also use this api and
also use the bing api and it being their
first port of call their first choice
but it's not because it's like an alien
landscape you land there and it's like
you're working with a completely
different company and so that's bad for
cross-selling so that's one of the
reasons why consistency is important
and i don't believe they've they've
solved this problem
does this resonate with people the
people that people looked at these
different apis they feel different from
microsoft
yes no no you all just use azure you
don't care about office
that you're agreeing to that we don't
care about office
that might be why though you know like
if you could reasonably easily access
this this office api and use the google
sheet google sheets what's called excel
um thing but the theory is adoption
across these platforms gets much more
interesting and much much uh much more
easy so having the right abstraction
layer in places is really important
um being able to do things like request
response manipulation is critical that's
how you're going to be able to like
build in if we'd have had a good enough
gateway at microsoft and i'll be
brutally honest api management was very
early in its journey at the point we
tried to do this this was like
eight years ago probably um
it wasn't capable of handling either the
scale or the complexity of all of the
different api products we had at
microsoft to actually form one api
service there was that and there was
political challenges honestly was the
other reason um but if we'd have
invested in it early enough and had a a
good enough gateway solution across all
of those apis
i think it would have been a very
solvable problem i think um i think it
would have been it would have put us in
a much better place
so other things you can do
with these abstractions that allow you
to be a more dynamic business
um is being able to respond to customers
so let me give you some like real
examples of things that have happened
since i've launched my business
um so
we have one customer who
they have an api it's v1 they're using
url url-based versioning
and that routes into one of their
kubernetes clusters and all the traffic
goes that way and then they decided they
were going to make a non-breaking change
to their back end so the back end was
going to do some super fast cool
processing i don't really understand
what it did but it was better but the
api was going to be the same
and they weren't ready to release it to
their customers yet they're just not
ready to give it to them because we
don't think it's stable
but then one of their customers their
most important powerful customer came to
them and said we want that
we want that latest version and we want
it now
like what to do do they
do they set up another api just for that
customer
seems kind of painful right
so no what they did um actually funny
enough i gave them a demo of the product
i work on now
and they weren't interested but then
three days later this customer called
and suddenly they became a customer
because what they did was they had the
requests come in they used the
abstraction layer of a gateway and
having this kind of abstraction is
what's critical to be able to redirect
all traffic from that one customer just
off to this back end so there's simply a
sort of if statement in the gateway that
says
if it's customer a we're going to send
them off to that piece of code if it's
customer b we're going to send them off
to this
these these abstractions are extremely
powerful once you've set this these
things up it's very easy but it also
allows you to do things like let's
imagine you have a customer you go you
go the api key route you decide you're
going to use api keys as your
authentication mechanism right
so you go the api key route and then one
customer decides he doesn't like it
because it's not standardized
ship says you know i'd like you to do
something else i'd like you to do job
tokens you're like oh go so now i've got
to go into my api actually meddle with
the code and somehow wire in an option
to do jot authentication if you have the
right abstraction with a gateway that's
usually just clicky click drag you drop
i'm just going to turn on jot
authentication as an additional option
and you're off to the races
so that's some of the reasons why i
think this is important um
so uh you know you could use some
middleware libraries like uh most of you
are net developers i'm guessing so you
know with asp.net there's a bunch of
like plugins you can put in the
intercept the request pipeline i'm
assuming the stuff on youget that can do
some of this stuff probably might not be
that hard to add adjob processing to api
key auth but it does end up kind of
meddled into your code um and adds some
complexity to the base
you can just write code of course you're
all developers you all have like
superpowers where you can write code
solve any problem that's the best thing
about being a developer or you can use
the gateway
and you might have noticed i'm saying
this a lot
i believe in this so much i created a
gateway company um
you should use a gateway
it's like crazy that if you're going to
launch an api or have an api
not to have a gateway take most of this
nonsense extract it out and give you all
of these abstraction layers
and the good news is there are tons of
options there are lots and lots of
gateway options out there let's talk
about some of them there is azure api
management which some people have
mentioned there's a good gateway there's
aws api gateway there's gcp api gateway
kong
tyke actually a british business i think
istio
envoy apogee any i've missed out
gravity is another one yeah i've heard
of those folks that's like a
open source i think you install it
yourself right um
is it hosted as well okay did you use
that one
okay
um any of this
no that's it okay um so there's a
question i get asked them when i say
this like why did i start
an api gateway company given that
there's all of these options
and there's a few reasons
um i think
most of them are quite hard to use
they're
not really designed for developers in
the way i think of a developer product
and what what i want it to do
they're not fun
which i think is really important you
know when i think about like great
software tools i actually enjoy
using them the number of folks
i talk to who describe the pain of using
some of the other products i've
mentioned
and here's the key point though
they're like they're like kryptonite to
your superpowers
because most of them you can't actually
do what you're great at to solve a
problem so let's imagine you know with
any gateway you're going to get 80
percent of the way to where you're going
to go
um
by using the built-in policies you know
so azure api management you folks are
using has a pretty healthy list of
policies it's probably going to cover 80
of what you need to do but what i had so
this is this is the gateway in theory
like what is a gateway you have your
clients that might be your mobile app it
might be uh your partners or or someone
else they're going to call the gateway
that's going to take care of things like
authentication authorization protection
docs
versioning maybe some analytics as well
and that then calls your api that's how
a gateway works it's usually a separate
process that sits somewhere but what i
have encountered in reality
is this
is that
most folks they deploy the gateway takes
care of some stuff but then they end up
having to write some kind of wrapper to
do the projection the transformation and
they write code and they deploy that as
an api that actually sits in front of
their api and it was when i kept seeing
this pattern i'm like this is crazy like
why aren't we letting developers do what
they do best why aren't we letting them
write code and so that was why we
created zuplo because in this place you
can actually write code that runs in the
gateway extremely high performance and
you can do
all of this stuff in uh
actually running in the gateway and so
you get rid of all of that complexity it
gives you like it's the ultimate
abstraction layer and that's why we
built it
i think if you'll if you'll forgive me
i'd love to give you a little demo of
the product that sounds okay you want to
see it in action
talk about it now again i um i don't
want to be like a hard salesperson here
but hopefully the main message of what
you're seeing today is
uh i will be happy if you all go away
and start using gateways more and
thinking about these abstractions and
have some useful thoughts about
versioning and like why i'm opinionated
about that and why these big companies
choose those versioning strategies and
why they um
why they tend to use api keys why that's
important
and of course we've embedded all that
that knowledge into the product i've
built um but yeah that's the main thing
i wanted you to take away so let's take
a look at the product in action
so you folks can actually go and try
this
just go to
portal.zuplo.com
and as i mentioned actually if um if you
follow that qr code i showed you before
you can actually come and do an exercise
in here and you'll get a chance to win a
drone come and show me at the booth i'll
give you some stickers if you haven't
already got one i think i gave you most
of you a sticker and um you can um
you'll also get a five dollar starbucks
gift card so what i'm gonna do right now
let's have some fun
is i'm gonna create a new gateway and
actually you're all gonna play along so
have your films ready because you're all
going to you're actually going to have
the gateway live and you're all going to
try and break it and you might do
because we're just going to use a free
developer instance but i love doing live
demos there's nothing like taking a bit
of risk it makes it makes this way more
interesting for all of us doesn't it so
we'll accept the default name of tomato
dolphin
my charger just fell out
and that's actually going to create a
gateway and you'll see just how quick
that's coming together so my ui is ready
and actually everything i'm doing in
here is a file so you can do everything
i'm showing you here you can actually do
in visual studio code we just have a
pretty web version as well you can do
either and everything that configures
the gateway is a file and notice the
gateway is actually live already so i'm
going gonna share it with you you can
all go and see it but before i do that i
need to add a route so a route is the
heart actually i'll try and share with
you as well like what's common about a
gateway just in case folks aren't super
familiar like a lot of the patterns in
here are available in other gateways and
i would encourage you to try them all
and my hope is you know the reason you
choose zuplo if you decide to go that
way is because it's a better experience
that's your decision to make so most of
the concepts are very familiar across
all the gateways so this is our route
designer this is where we're going to
set up all the routes so when you think
about it request is going to come into
the gateway hit that gateway and then
it's going to decide what it's going to
do with it and in most cases it's just
going to kind of forward it on to some
of the url so let's add let's add a
route that does that right now so i'm
going to click add route
it's going to be on the root path right
it's going to support get we can support
multiple methods
i'm going to give it a a label let's
call it root path
versioning look we have like built-in
url versioning so you can see that adds
a v1 or not and then of course do you
want cross-origin resource sharing huge
headache to implement this correctly let
a gateway do it for you don't write this
stuff yourself it's just so much easier
to have this in a configuration layer
um
we have two options here but you can
actually also configure custom options
to allow cross-origin resource sharing
for certain domains
and what happens is when a request
matches this section
it's going to do a rewrite to this url
to welcome.zuplor.io so what i'm going
to show you now is a little webpage so
this is the web page and we're just
going to proxy that now for the purposes
of demo right
we have a little route tester built up
here it's quite handy just allows me to
test my routes like getting routing
right in a gateway is quite tricky
because it's often doing manipulation to
what the url looks like you know it
might like take query strings and make
them into parameters and so we have a
little built-in test client that will do
that in real time so i'll just show you
then actually goes oh yeah we match this
thing called root path there it is and
this is what the rewrite is going to
look like it's just going to forward it
on to that url right so i'm going to
save that change that's going to be
instantly live and i'm going to copy
this url and get your phones out
get ready
we're going to go and generate a qr code
you can all go and hit this api
and i'm just going to hope you don't
break it
can you see that is it scannable
people got it
are you getting the little your api's
live page
yeah thumbs up
awesome okay we've not broke it yet
let's let's try harder um
so now what i want to do is let's say
let's talk about protection i'm going to
protect this api from all you nasties
that are trying to take it down so let's
go and put some rate limiting on so what
we're going to do i'm going to close
down the route tester here we're going
to open up the policy stack and we're
going to add a policy and you can see
there's tons of policies in here giotto
authentication for auth0
uh open id jot authentication cognito
jot off json body validation
validate the bodies take your swagger
document if you have a swagger or an
open api document shove that into a
gateway most support it and they'll
validate the requests before they send
it on to your back end it's just so easy
just takes care of so many edge cases
and uh and just removes like so much
headache from your actual api but what
we're going to do is going to turn on
rate limiting i'm going to rate limit by
ip as you can see here is it can you
read this is it big enough
yeah okay great
i'm going to rate limit by ip but
actually one of the things we're very
proud of in zuplo is we've made it very
programmable i talked about like the
kryptonite to your superpowers and i
wanted to unblock that i want to make it
so you can write code i'm going to show
you a bunch of examples of that but you
can rate limit by ip you can rate limit
by user so that's when you add
authentication to the stack but my
favorite is you can actually rate limit
by function and what you get to do then
is write a little javascript or
typescript function that decides how the
rate limiting is going to work and
that's really important because when you
really think about rate limiting you
don't want to set the rate limits by ip
i mean pretty random right if you've got
an actual partner
you don't really want to set it by user
either you want to set it by customer
type
you probably have a free customers
they're going to get a much stricter
rate limit you're going to have premium
customers you might have that one
special super partner who has a much
higher rate limit that's actually very
hard to do on most gateways with zoopla
you can write a piece of code that can
literally return and say for this
customer based on this request i want to
do a thousand requests per minute or you
know whatever number you like can
actually even call a database to go and
check that you can call your amazon
dynamodb or your azure blob storage or
whatever storage you want to you can
invoke that in code but just for the
purposes of demo we're going to do ip
i'm guessing most of you are sharing an
ip now so you might all get rate limited
right away we'll see it i'm going to
save that but i did two requests in one
minute so if you all start refreshing
that page
you should all start seeing that you're
getting rate limited pretty quickly
and also notice the speed at which like
this is happening right there's actually
a lot happening in the background i'm
taking a bunch of typescript code
compiling that down deploying it and
right now we're running on our in our
one of our us data centers when you
deploy zuplo we think the best place for
a for a gateway is at the edge so it's
one click deploy we have a couple of
deployment options we can deploy on-prem
as well
um but uh the default deployment option
we put you at the edge in 250 data
centers around the world because really
you want your gateway as close to your
client as possible because when you
start using caching and doing
authentication termination it just makes
for a much better experience it's one
click we deploy in about four seconds to
actual production as well it's very very
fast and we use git ops to do that so
you push you can see the github is not
lit up here because i haven't connected
my github repo but you can do that in
visual studio code you push to main if
you're familiar with the first cell it
works very similar to two percel
okay so we've got um let's see we've got
we've got the rate limiting working so
that's pretty nice um i meant what were
the other four things i talked about
well let's add some authentication now
now i've shown you jot tokens um that's
pretty easy but actually what i want to
do is do api key authentication so we're
going to add the api key authentication
policy now i want to i probably want to
authenticate before our rate limit
because i might use user-based rate
limiting right so i'm going to put the
authentication in there and actually i'm
going to save that now and then when
this thing stops spinning it'll be live
and if you folks hit it again now you'll
see that you actually get an
unauthorized response you don't have the
key right so you're not coming in no no
no
my api is now secure which is really
nice
um
but how do i get a user so one of the
challenges when you're doing api key
authentication is there's a lot to think
about like it's very easy to do this
part this is kind of easy it's like we
call a database how this works right the
request comes in we say oh this person's
got apiq authentication let's check for
a key and there's no key in your request
that you're sending so we just go nope
you're not coming in if there is a key
we have to go and call a database we
want to call a database we check if that
key exists who's the customer what's
their information but we don't want to
call a database in every request so then
when we get the first response we have a
very high performance cache that runs at
the edge in a distributed way that's
synced so that for all of the other
requests it's super super fast it takes
like milliseconds we tend to have like
10 to 50 milliseconds to most requests
but then there's the whole problem if
you're building your own api key
solution of so now i need a database
where i store keys and i have to have a
ui where people can come and access
their keys and roll their keys etc and
it becomes a pain well of course we have
an option for that built in
a lot of gateways do this as well we're
not the only one
and so let's add a new consumer so a
consumer is like a customer um let's
pretend the customer is uh
the police are on my mind after last
night let's pretend it's the police
uh and then we say who is the manager
who are the managers that can manage
these keys so this would this would be
where you put like your customers email
address i don't happen to have any
police email addresses so i'm just going
to put mine in because it'll make for a
better demo um so that's and you can
have this email address if you want to
ask me any questions josh zuplow.com and
then i'm going to associate some oops
then i'm going to associate some
metadata with this customer and i'm
doing this in the ui but of course
there's an api for this like you could
do all of this setup through through an
api or a script um
and what metadata should we do well we
talked about like having customer type
so we'll have this is going to be a
premium customer very nice to the police
and let's say then we wanted to build
some sort of authorization scheme so i'm
going to say roles let's make it
like a list of possible roles this
person's a member of we're going to make
them an admin because the police they
have superpowers i'm going to save that
so now my api is a potential consumer
i don't get to see their keys it's not
my business that's for them to see so
where would they do that well i
mentioned the other important part of
your launch plan for your public api is
to have documentation so what i want to
do quickly though is just add some more
routes let's make this a more
interesting api so let's add another
route
let's do a post
instead of a get to
hello ndc i'm just making stuff up now
really let's add some
json schema validation
and we have an example schema built in
so i'm just going to use that i want to
write a json schema in front of you but
you're all familiar with the idea that's
probably enough for now so i'm going to
save that
and
we should be good and so now notice that
i have this link up at the top left that
says go and view your developer portal
so we actually the whole time we're
doing this we're actually generating a
developer portal for you with
documentation that would help your
developers um go and see how to use your
api and so you can see
it just disappeared why to do that
so you can see here your um
you can see here all the different
methods you've got so we've got like the
root method you this is how to curl this
i've got a hello ndc method down here
and
notice i also have this consumer key
here that i can create so i can now
create a key
that this person can use excuse the
formatting in this this window that i
can use to call my api so i want to show
you this in action and to do that i've
got to set a header because it comes in
on the header and we actually have a
built-in test client that makes it
really easy to test your api you can use
postman or insomnia or whatever tool you
use but i'm just going to do this one
because it's here i'm not we're not
trying to compete with insomnia so let's
go and add a new test i'm just going to
call this ndc
that's going to create me a little test
file
and i'm going to do a get on the route
because that was where we put the api
and if i call this you'll see i got a
401 unauthorized you can see
all of the headers i get etc and
and the response that i'm getting here
as well everything's very laggy at the
moment my computer is running very slow
let me just try and reload that
okay
so let's test it again oh i didn't save
my changes that'll teach me
i'm gonna delete that do a test and
you'll see now i get a 401 unauthorized
as expected right so i'm going to do
authorization
as the header borrower
i paste in the token i hit test
and we are off to the races i now get a
200 okay and you can see i'm getting
that welcome to ziploc page so that's
how easy it is to add so i've covered a
couple of bases now i've got my
authentication sorted i'm using api keys
which i like because it's easier for
everybody to use i've got my
documentation sorted i've got my
protection we're pretty much off to the
races so now what i want to show you is
some of the ideas around
abstraction
so if i go back to that routing table
you'll notice that we have a couple of
options here on this on this request
handler right it says url rewrite so a
url rewrite simply rewrites the url and
targets some different backend
actually a lot of power here
if you're an aws lambda customer we can
call a lambda directly now
most of you are probably azure customers
i'm guessing given the nature of this
conference but uh the way to expose
lambda is through aws api gateway
typically zoopla actually outperforms um
api gateway when calling lambda so it's
a popular option for that but my
favorite is to write a function
so i can actually write some code here
my mac is very much locking up
it's all frozen
i'm just going to restart chrome a
minute here
was this the one we were working on was
it called tomato dolphin
okay good
okay so i'm gonna show you the function
version of this which i really like um
so in this case what i can do is i can
actually write code when my mouse works
again
so here i'm going to save that and if i
show you this code
you can actually do anything in here
that you can do in javascript or
typescript so what this is going to do
is going to return a string that says
what's up that's our funny way of saying
hello world because you know we're funny
like that um i'm going to save that but
actually before i have you try it let me
go and remove the authentication policy
on the rate limit because you folks can
actually try that using that same url so
if you go and hit that url now it should
actually be live and you should see that
you get a message what's up come back to
you right and just to prove it that it's
real i'm going to do it again i'm going
to change it i'm going to say what's up
ndc exclamation mark
save deployed
oh save deployed live hit it again you
should see you get that change
right
so this is where people are doing the
really smart abstraction this is very
high performance it runs inside the
gateway in process there are no process
hops
and uh it's crazy quick it's crazy how
fast this is so what i have people doing
for example remember that story about
the customer that had
he had a bad customer that wanted the
latest beta version so what he did was
if request.user so he can inspect the
user as it comes in dot sub equals let's
say bad customer
no customers are bad though so that's
not true then he's going to return so
i'm actually starting to proxy now in
code this is simply going to return
what's at the url let's do central
microsoft fans let's do microsoft.com
i mean obviously i prefer to proxy apis
but web pages make for better demos
otherwise for all other customers return
fetch
example.com
so if i say that if you'll hit that url
again you'll actually see that you get
example.com because you're all good
customers
is that what you see you get the idea so
extremely powerful there's tons of stuff
you can do in here you can call
databases you can use our caching system
um extremely flexible and actually my
favorite place for writing code is not
as a handler although that's pretty cool
like yeah
i think if you can purchase all the
gateways you'll find this uh that's
pretty unique but actually you can also
write custom policies this is my
favorite place to do this so you come in
here
you do custom code inbound you specify a
policy and i'm not going to write that
for you now i'm not going to bore you
with with yet more code but you'll get
the idea what you can actually do is
very similar to the code you just saw me
write in the request handler you can
apply that to all your policies and
people write custom authorization
schemes here because let me show you
actually i'll just show you one last
quick quick demo let's change this code
so what it does is
it just echoes the user back to you so
return
request.user.sub now i need to actually
add a user here again so i'm going to
have to add authentication so let me add
back api key auth inbound i'll save that
and if i go back to my test client and i
invoke that now
so we're going to do a get on the root
to clear that one
authorization
bearer
paste
test
notice what i actually get back
is police because that's the user sub
right that's actually what i what i had
the code return
actually that should would have been
better demo if i did just return
request.user so i'm going to save that
so you can't try this because you don't
have my api key i'm not giving you
but now you'll see i get all of this
data the sub is police
the roles are admin the customer type is
premium so i can use this information
inside my custom policy i can use it
inside my rate limiter to decide oh it's
a premium customer i'm going to give
them 100 requests per minute instead of
one per minute or whatever the number
would be or this particular route is
going to be protected for people who
have admin privileges or whatever scopes
you come up with so people do some
really creative stuff in here one of my
favorites actually was a company that's
using us that ingests data to their ai
processing back end
and
as that data comes in we just send it on
to their back end but the back end can
be a little flaky it goes down sometimes
so they came to us and said can we have
a custom policy that i put on all of our
routes that archives all incoming
requests azure blob storage actually
there's a video of me how you do this uh
online and so we wrote this together in
like 20 minutes honestly 20 minutes
they've been running in production with
that now for four and a half months and
every single request that comes in they
archive to blob storage so if they go
down they can then replay those requests
later and in fact they change the code
to always return to 200. so now the
customers don't even know they've gone
down so they have 100 uptime which is
good because they're not losing any data
they're actually processing it but their
customers just think they're awesome so
they're very very happy campers thanks
to a solution like that and that's what
i mean about the importance of having
the um the right abstractions in place
so i'm going to pop back to my slides
let me just open these up
and then go right to the end and then we
will wrap up um but yeah that's
basically
um hopefully useful talk for you about
some of the key ideas of like how these
big companies approach
uh building and scaling a large api and
based on my own experiences the story of
why i decided to found a company like
zuplo because i want to kind of give
developers that use gateways their
superpowers back and the ability to
write code like this and iterate super
super quickly and do a lot with all of
that abstraction so as i remembered uh
this is the competition you probably
have the card in your hands anyway i
think we've only had like five entries
so far so it's well worth doing it if
you want to win a drone plus you can
also get that five dollar starbucks gift
card
and you can always try out this product
as well go check it out go to
portal.zuplo.com
sign in
give us your feedback
let us know what you think
and at that point i think we're probably
just about in time to finish so thanks
for coming along hope it was useful
please come and say hi to me i'm going
to be down at the booth on floor 3 at
the end of the room on the right
i'm happy to talk to you about anything
azure api management any of my
experiences working at these companies
building apis come and have a chat with
nate and i nate's an interesting guy as
well he uh he was head of developer
platform at salesforce and he was um he
was an early employee author he actually
built out all the documentation and sdks
so come and come and talk to us thanks
folks thanks